good to see you virtually you look
amazing
so do you you look so cute i love fried
eye um
how are you doing right now with
everything girl
yeah well right before i got on this
call i just read that
stay at home got extended until august
so i'm digesting that you take it day by
day
and i think that some days are harder
for others and i have to keep in
perspective like
i'm just grateful i have sunshine i have
my dog um
it's been a little hard doing it alone
like we need human connection
and so i think i'm feeling a little i
think we're all feeling it at this point
but
staying optimistic eating a lot of crap
food and yeah watching a lot of tv
yeah i'm i'm with you are you so you're
alone you're not even like with family
or anything like that that's gotta be no
i really should have made the call to go
to tennessee to be with my family but
no one could have predicted that it
would go this long
i feel like tom hanks and castaway like
i'm talking to things that aren't here
it's just crazy there are wild times
that we're living in i do want to talk
about
katy kino this entire season was such a
fun watch
i want to break down the finale with you
though as the new owner of lacy's i
would like to announce that this
establishment
will remain open prince errol or do we
just call him arrow now
i since he has stepped down yeah we'll
just call him errol
although prince errol has a gotta it's
catchy i like it i know i kind of like
saying prince arrow
um yeah what does that mean for him and
katie keane because they sort of had
this
a little bit romantic connection and now
he's technically
is he her boss now he's technically
the big boss in charge and uh so katie's
got a few
men in her life and she's got some
options
um but i guess you know where we end off
the season
anything goes like it could easily go in
the direction of guy or ko
or prince errol so we kind of leave it
up to
you know to next season to see what's
going to happen but it definitely like
i've sort of come up with some
narratives in my mind and it'll just be
interesting to see
if i'm completely off or not how do you
feel like things are really set up for
season two i would assume we're getting
that season two right
well along with a lot of other things
going on
so much is up in the air i think the
biggest thing with our show now is that
it films in new york
and who knows when filming will
resume there so it's kind of
everything's uncertain so it's kind of a
scary time for a lot of things but i'm
like i said remaining optimistic and the
great thing about katie keane is that
you know if and when we get a season two
the show is just so fun
we're singing we're dancing we've got
romance we've got drama we've got
fashion
so we leave off in a good spot for
everyone in the show and i think that
katie's taking the next step
at becoming a designer we leave everyone
off in a pretty optimistic spot and i
what i love about the finale is that
everyone chooses themself like they're
like i'm gonna fall in love with myself
i'm gonna fall in love with my dream
and i kind of think that that's cool
what about the whole leo lacey situation
because the very end of the episode
she's like i think you're my dad
do you think that that's katie's dad you
know we would have given it to him
really easy if it is but
i hope so purely based on who they cast
he's amazing and i love that katie just
immediately jumps to i think you're my
dad
she's that's just her in a nutshell she
doesn't have a filter
yeah we love her for it yeah as of
yesterday i stepped down from the royal
family
i'm financially independent what did you
think of the prince harry
reference because obviously
you know yeah financially independent
um it definitely did and i love our show
because we have some we have a lot of
pop culture references
in the show like that so it was just
perfect timing we needed
prince harry and megan to step away so
we could have that lovely story line in
katy keith so we're very grateful
have you ever met meghan markle or
prince harry in real life
so get this i did my first ever pilot
with meghan markle
what i didn't realize this because none
of my scenes were with her but it was an
abc pilot when i was
i just moved to l.a i was like 16. it
was called secrets of a small town
and she was in that pilot and i remember
at the table reed i was like oh my god
she's
so beautiful but i don't think i ever
spoke to her
um but i've never met prince harry only
in my dreams
yeah that's so funny though that you
guys were in that pilot together
it's a small world yeah look what's
happened now
now she's who she is it's great it's
good yeah
happy for her um that's such a funny
story um i also have to ask you about mr
mark consuelos
apparently yes yes dream boat
yes uh so i was sad because
my i didn't katie wasn't written into
that scene
so i didn't get to work with him or meet
him but
you know i love his wife i love kelly
and i i've you know met her numerous
times so i was i was looking forward to
meeting him but
he missed me this time we'll have to
cross paths in another universe yeah
they sort of set it up for more of his
character on katie keane because you
think it's time for me to come home
essentially
what did you make of that i love it and
i think that
from what i hear riverdale is flash
forwarding so
if they're because our show takes place
five years in the future so if riverdale
and katie keene are on the same timeline
i feel like there could be really cool
crossovers i hope
you know cw's listening because
i've got ideas and veronica could come
to new york
and because uh how they set it up in
riverdale is that katie and veronica
are buds like they're italian yeah is
there a character on
riverdale that hasn't been on katy keen
yet that you would love to see make
an appearance yeah veronica
obviously don't feel like we need some
spicy cheryl
and katie keane i just love her i love
madeleine and i just
what she's done with that character is
so great and she loves red cheryl and
katie both love red
and they can bond over red lipstick do
you guys ever
imagine what could have been like what
if i would have said
yes to ko's proposal it's funny because
in this episode of katie keane you guys
sort of posed the question of like what
if what if you had said yes to ko's
proposal
what if you had done this or that is
there
a role that you said no to that you sort
of always wonder like what if i said yes
to this i i often have these
conversations well i have two i
so i i remember i was supposed to go in
to read for pitch
perfect and i forget why i didn't it was
some dumb reason
and sure enough that movie was so
great i would have killed to be a part
of it but also
before i took the role of pretty little
liars i had to choose between
uh pll or this other like tv movie
i would be so devastated if i took that
tv movie
and my whole life would be different i
feel like pll wouldn't have been what it
was without
arya without you ah well you're sweet
you're sweet but it would have been sad
watching it and being like
damn i could have been a part of that
three things that you would want to see
in a potential
katie keen season two
oh goodness three things
more new york city more
musicals um
um and crossovers like you said like
riverdale crossovers
chilling adventures of sabrina
crossovers
is there room for a sabrina crossover
probably not they're so like different
but we do have
so the guy who plays the devil on
sabrina
plays guy on i know
there's wild comments about it on
twitter by the way
yeah it's it's pretty wet so he's
obviously not playing the devil on katie
keane but
um but they do like kind of keep
everyone in the universe which is pretty
cool
not to like make it all about the
romances but fans are invested
who do you think is better suited for
katie is it guy
is it errol or is it heyo i know
i'm just like can't she have all three
though
it's like i see so many
i don't know it's hard it's so hard it's
like
a huge part of me is like ko and katie
because they're high school sweethearts
and i'm like
a guy is so sexy and tall but earl's got
an
accent so i don't know i was gonna say
like ko and katie because it's like
we always root for the like the og
you know